after Thursday's snowstorm the snow in
Chile town was 55 centimeters deep
on Friday the snow kept coming and
several more centimetres Val's okay
they're getting a lot of snow now the
snow in Chile town is 84 84 centimeters
deep how many centimetres of snow fell
on Friday so let's look at this diagram
again just so that we can imagine what
went on so the first time so the snow in
Chile town so after there's there's a
storm on Thursday and then the snow in
Chile town was 55 centimeters deep and
they show that to us right over here so
this is that 55 centimeters is this
point on the ruler so this is how deep
this is how deep the snow was after the
storm after the storm on Thursday this
is how deep so this this depth right
over here is 55 centimeters but the sono
did not stop it kept coming so now the
snow in Chile town is 84 centimeters
deep so in the ruler that's this right
over here 84 centimeters deep so they
want to know how much how many
centimeters of snow fell on Friday so
they want us to figure out what is this
amount right over here what is the
amount that fell on Friday they even put
the question mark right over here
question mark centimeters so how do we
figure that out well let's just write
some let's write some some some things
that we know are true
so we know that 55 centimeters 55
centimeters plus however many
centimeters this was so I'll write
question centimeters so this is how many
were after the Thursday snowstorm plus
however many fell on Friday we don't
know that so I'm just going to write a
question mark over there that's going to
be equal to the total that's equal to 84
centimeters that's equal to 84
centimeters so we just need to figure
out what is this question mark well one
way to figure out what this question
mark is if 55 plus question mark is 84
then that means that means that 84 minus
55 minus 55
is going to be equal to the question
mark is going to be equal to the
question mark and one way to think about
it is if you had all the snow and if you
were to subtract out 55 centimeters of
it you're just going to be left with the
question mark amount because the
difference between 84 and 55 is what
fell on Friday the difference between 84
and 55 so let's figure out what that is
so I could do that I'm running out of
space here I'll do it down here so we
have 84 84 minus 55 minus 55 and that's
going to be equal to our question mark
so let's look at our ones place we have
four ones minus five ones well since we
don't know how to do that since 4 is
less than five so let's regroup so let's
take a 10 from the tens place instead of
having eight 10s there let's have seven
10s there and then make that extra that
10 we just took turn that into 10 ones
so 10 plus 4 is 14 so now we can
subtract 14 ones minus 5 ones let me
move down a little bit 14 ones minus 5
ones is 9 ones 7 tens minus 5 tens is 2
tens so our mystery amount of snow 29
centimeters so this right over here is
29 centimeters and you can check that 55
plus 29 is indeed equal to 84 I
encourage you to try to to to check that
that does definitely work so how many
centimeters of snow fell on Friday 29 29
centimeters the important thing for
problems like this is just imagine the
story imagine what's going on and then
and then draw diagrams they didn't draw
it for you and then think about writing
some some math statements some some
people would call number sentences or
equations that you know are going to be
true and then you can figure out what
you don't know